[Music]
when you enter cenote it's really like
going into another world like living
leaving the planet behind
this is a feeling of really exploring
something new
and i feel very lucky to be able to see
that
[Music]
my name is uh julian bird i've been free
diving and scuba diving for the last 15
years in many different locations always
trying to find the best diving spots
those cenotes are archives
all the cenotes are connected to each
other and the the water goes and flows
from one sanote to another cenote to end
up in the sea
the first time you you go into
simultaneously it's something you don't
see anywhere else it's completely a
different experience than diving in the
ocean
at the beginning it can be a little bit
scary
but really quickly the beauty of the
place would just take over
some cenotes are very welcoming
sometimes so big and so clear that uh it
really gives you the sensation you go
into a church and you don't want to talk
too loud to not disturb anyone
and some of the cenotes i also have a
little bit like an atmosphere more like
hell with
dead trees in the bottom and sulfur
the mayans were using the cenotes
for a very long time
basically the land where we are that's
the place where the living people lives
and then underneath the cenotes into the
ground was the place for the dead
[Music]
everything that i have a different
personality
but i also think that he really affects
your own personality
at some point you
kind of enter into like a meditation
state that for me is
completely priceless
[Music]
it's taken six thousand years for nature
to carve these remarkable formations
the marble caves of chile chico are
located on a peninsula of solid marble
bordering a remote glacial lake that
spans the chile argentina border
the lake is fed by rivers coming from
several surrounding glaciers
as the glaciers melt and grow the waters
slowly carve out the marble leaving
behind masterpieces fit for a museum
these distinct bright blue waters are
caused by suspended particles from the
glaciers reflecting the blue part of
sunlight
getting to this location isn't easy it's
a long journey requiring a flight a 200
mile drive into the wilderness and a
boat ride just to get there
but it's worth it
the remarkable swirling patterns on the
cave reflect the lake's blue waters
changing with the water levels and the
season
nature truly is the greatest artist
anytime i'm inside a cave i feel i'm in
a different time scale
above the ground is
much
faster the tree grows and dies in like
100 years
but inside the caves it's millions of
years and it's
timeless
eleven miles north of beirut hidden
inside a mountain lies the jata grotto
the pride of lebanon and one of the most
majestic caves in the world
when we say jeta cave everybody knows
jita gave it's a very important cave
because it's the main water source of of
beirut and the area nearby rule
a small portion of the jaita grotto is
open to the public the rest is
accessible only to a select few
including the spilio club founded in
1951 it's the oldest most respected
caving club in the middle east the
spirit club de lebon was founded during
the explorations of jaita grotto the
same history of our club is the history
of jaita grotto every week the spilio
club gets together and goes caving in
the grotto when they explore they travel
by boat down a subterranean black lake
their mission is to discover new caves
map them photograph them and ultimately
protect them
there's no doubt that shahita glitter is
really a work of art simply because
of its huge scale and its huge
formations
and those formations aren't set in stone
the cave is very much alive
all of this is still undergrowing it's
not a fossil cave yet it's still leaving
this cave
in the last 65 years the spilio club has
discovered over 600 caves
every weekend their work goes on we
can't say that we had explored all jeta
caves because each two years or one
years we discovered new things so we are
still working inside jetta and we will
not finish
[Music]
to play the instrument
that is utilizing
our gentle earth
it's like
you are becoming one with the instrument
in a very true way you just sit and go
yes
we're looking at the great stalag pipe
organ of the luray caverns in luray
virginia
when i press a key it sends an
electrical pulse up to a rubber tipped
mallet
which strikes the stalactite causing it
to vibrate and producing a
incredibly beautiful musical tone
the area that the strikers cover is
roughly three and a half acres which
then makes it literally the world's
largest musical instrument
it is a very gentle sound um very
peaceful
there's only one like it in the world
and
it's something
incredibly different and wonderfully
beautiful
[Music]
what i love about seeing bats is just
how graceful they are
the way they fly they flip they flutter
they move
they're just stunning
it was just kind of a love at first
sight that has stayed with me my entire
life
they're just part of my world
[Music]
i am kirsten alvi mudd
the executive director and founder of
missouri bat census
and i'm a bat lady
when we heard word in 2006 about white
nose syndrome
i knew that we had a very short window
white nose syndrome is a fungus it grows
on a bat's nose on its wings on its tail
anywhere where the bat doesn't have fur
it causes it to wake too many times from
its winter hibernation sleep
they may hang where they're at in a cave
and just starve to death
or fly out on a cold day and will be
lost on the landscape
see these little blotches in his wing
that's what we're looking for
it also invades a bat's wings tissue
and it eats away at their wings
hey but it's almost spring buddy you got
a chance to make it some of your roomies
did not survive
see how we have a dead bed here another
bat right there
another good sized one there
it's really hard not just because i
enjoy the caving but i enjoy the bats
themselves and i just want to do
everything to protect them and help them
hang on until we find some method that
we can intervene on their behalf
[Music]
we've began our bat rescue and rehab
programs here in the state of missouri
are you hungry
right now the bats that i have at my
location are all big brown bats these
guys all came into us as little orphaned
hairless pups
in the next few weeks they'll be getting
a chance to see if they can fly and eat
and maintain their weight on their own
in the hopes of releasing them back into
the wild are you looking for more
there are so many misconceptions about
bats
i just wish that everybody would realize
that
they have an integral part of our
ecosystem
there's a real sense of pride that we
have helped these bats gain in
population numbers
nobody has to pat me on the back for it
i feel it it's the thank you from them
as i see many more and more of them
surviving and living healthy and happy
that's what i'm out for
do
[Music]
you